[Musique]
ils ont écrit l'histoire de cette
aventure à nulle autre pareille vingt
ans de dépassement de soi pour monter
quand est vraiment délicate
il y a des athlètes qui veut signer ce
possible
cette année ils reviennent pour en
découdre j'ai envie de montrer que je
fais partie de la légende c'est ce que
c'est de chercher à la gare dont le
coeur va la vendre bienvenue dans koh
lanta là les gens
jetaient des vous taisez vous taisez
vous quant au camping paradis fait
extraordinaire il me dit de camping
paradis voilà ça fait des grosses
audiences doivent donc la majorité n'a
pas encore sorti raison camping paradis
ne critique jamais camping paradis c'est
une de mes émissions préférées celles de
la culture tout est dit vous allez voir
votre achat d'or c'est du cassoulet qui
produit ça c'est un amen merci voilà
contrairement à vous qui est une
connaissance
et bientôt annoncer un collègue bon on
va passer on va revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé depuis le début de l'émission au
début de la saison les téléspectateurs
ont pu découvrir que leur aventuriers
préférer les légendes ont dû faire face
à des conditions très très compliqué
cette saison va tout vous raconter on va
revenir sur les dix d'infos et sur
michael dolto broad a également du
parisien qui a fini interview qui a dit
qu'il avait subi des énormes pressions
de tf1 je sais pas si un tu as peur à
tf1 un mec qui dit voilà je vais
t'attraper je vais te défoncer mais
apparemment voilà il ya des tapeurs là
bas je t'aimerai beaucoup d'espacé grand
merci
soyez les bienvenus dans koh lanta la
légende vous allez partir à la
découverte de l'endroit où vous allez
vivre dans les conditions les plus
spartiate écoutez bien sur place pas de
mal pas de bouc
uniquement deux machettes et évidemment
compte tenu de votre potentiel patrick
voilà donc colons tu as eu lieu au
septième jour de l'aventuré à contour
alexia diffusé le 9 novembre découvre tu
étais où ira sur la télomérase israël
par candidat aguerris respecté de tous a
triché il avoue devant les caméras de
son crime et se fait éliminé du jeu par
denis brogniart denis brogniart qui fait
malheureusement trouve lui dis bien
entendu c'est pas lui qui décide des
mini ou pas denis brogniart fait ce
qu'on lui dit il il a bien raison mais
ça peut pas faire d'autres choses nous
avons appris et nous avons eu la
confirmation qui à plusieurs reprises
vous avez demandé à des pêcheurs qui
passaient au large de la nourriture et
que plusieurs fois on vous a apporté à
manger c'est un comportement déloyal
qui constitue un manquement à l'éthique
aux règles de koh lanta il y aura
sanction vous allez directement
rejoindre
résidence du jury final pour vous
koh-lanta se termine aujourd'hui
[Musique]
s'en va la queue basse malheureusement
et le panier plein de friandises le
problème dans toute cette histoire c'est
que t'es où ira était loin d'être le
seul à avoir triché mushkin t oui
rappelez vous la semaine dernière mais
rien pas longs bas étaient avec nous et
elle avait révélé les cinq noms des
autres d'aventuré elle avait mis en
cause une tricherie en bande organisée à
la mairie coumba dedans combat qui n'a
pas mangé un j'ai vérifié j'ai eu ces
analyses d'urines tout elle n'a pas
mangé ne vous inquiétez pas donc voilà
combat t'es où ira à manger steak frites
légumes une seule fois glaude
l'orangeade sam et fils aurait mangé
chocolat mais aussi qu'aucun fromage des
pâtes et des pizzas tous les trois jours
c'est à dire qu'il était en rom service
sega
d'après le parisien un couple a été
particulièrement spitz année en ouvrant
ses portes et surtout sa cuisine aux
aventuriers de tf1 et enfin la grande
révélation de cette année c'est quand
même hugo le mec était éliminé puis il
est revenu pas une fois mais deux fois
en fait c'est un peu le gilles verdez de
colomb
regarde
on ne peut pas lâcher après tout ce
qu'il a enduré éliminés au premier
conseil de la vente
il a survécu aux cinq épreuves de la
reine fait bon j'ai donc gagné est
intégré à la réunification
tel un phénix il a remporté trois totems
sur 4 mais a été éliminé au dernier
conseil le phénix il est revenu face à
100 je vais pas lâcher la faire et je
vais essayer de remettre une deuxième
fois
voilà qui ne sait rien à rien c'est tout
bête comme dit on mais c'est à moi
on finit bien
et
maintenant confié tout ça quand on voit
toutes les images de koh lanta donc
c'est vrai que les aventuriers sur le
pli nié d'avoir énormément fin on se dit
que c'est pas cent mille euros qu'il
aurait dû gagner un oscar à hollywood
mais regardez
c'est bon
[Musique]
il reste de cuir de riz nous dit que de
cuir de riz à
6k rien et abbott manioc ya pas de canne
à sucre 1 du tout il ya un quadri faut
se contenter répondra essayaient de
passer dès que je me lève et jouable en
un peu de vertige mons normal ce jeu
très très peu de riz on n'a rien mais
bon c'est dans la tête en tiendra
jusqu'au bout franchement la nourriture
ici ça reste toujours le truc de
plusieurs à koh lanta sera celle de
nature les affamés mais un peu mytho
quand même
[Applaudissements]
les itunes à tous les aventuriers les
aime beaucoup c'est drôle et je pense
que ma me font rigoler oui pas facile de
retard 1 qui pour j'ai mangé j'en ai
fait une barque a fait j'ai regretté
voilà le grand rabbin on a appris à
pleyben bon voila j'ai passé à autre
chose
là comme c'est vrai je passe à autre
chose on va passer maintenant aux débris
de la finale l'émission a été suivie par
4 4 millions de téléspectateurs
la finale de l'an dernier avait
rassemblé 5,5 millions téléspectateurs
m'ont été l'année dernière qu'on était
en couvre feu et on aurait le vendredi
voire arrêtée vendredi d'ailleurs c'est
une énorme connerie d'abord mon colon
talent mardi je sais pas qui a eu l'idée
mais en tout cas je le félicite pas il
nous a flingué le koh lanta mois mardi
je mets des enfants ils n'ont plus
jamais regardé à koh lanta ça n'aide pas
ce que ses collègues là maintenant mardi
ils se retrouvent sur un truc de
meilleur sur tf1 et il regarde pas voilà
donc forcément le mardi c'est koh lanta
ils ont un petit peu sacrifie je le dis
mardi c'est lorsque tu dis ah non c'est
vrai c'est n'importe quoi rien mais qui
c'est qu'a déjà d'esprit mais là dessus
ce que j'ai dit à tf1 on est là pour
être partenaire on est là pour les aider
à ouvrir des cases l'aider ce qu'ils ont
besoin de bras une casquette mardi parce
qu'il ya de moins en moins de fiction
américaine ce que je trouve vraiment
dommage et ça je leur ai dit c'est que
si je l'avais su j'aurais fait des
émissions plus courte ben c'est sûr
parce que hermine en général vers 3h20
bien sûr qu'un seul enfant on le voit
bien sur la courbe les enfants s'en vont
et je n'avais pas ça correct même le
vote de longueuil se sont endormis mais
par rapport au jeune public qu'à un
public est très important chez nous je
sabré parvenir le vendredi ou pas
j'espère que je vais vous dire ce qu'a
fait tf1 aussi moi ce que je pense c'est
qu'ils sont dit qu'elle est la marque la
plus forte qu'elle est la marque qui est
la plus forte sur tf1 c'est koh lanta
dont qui lui on peut prendre un risque
et koh lanta parce que lui-même le mardi
ça va tenir il c'est vrai que le koh
lanta le problème qu'ont à koh-lanta
c'est que c'est un programme très
familial que les enfants adorent et que
le mardi c'est compliqué en pleine
semaine de se coucher afin de croiser
leurs 3h45 donc forcément tu te dis je
vais pas regarder le début de koh lanta
si je vois pas la fin donc c'est
compliqué mais pour vous donner mais
regardez jusqu'à la fin il s'avère
qu'elle s'est pas réveillé ce matin
l'école bah voilà donc voilà bah voila
moi j'ai des problèmes avec mon tiennent
[Rires]
pas pour rff a besoin de lui la chérie
c'est étonnant parce que cette finale
était très attendu tout le monde
s'attendait à de grosse explication de
la part des candidats ou même de la
production on va débriefer sur ce
problème de finale et après on verra sur
toutes les révélations bien entendu et
on commence avec la dernière épreuve de
koh lanta tourner en polynésie l'épreuve
iconique des poteaux à l'opposé les
trois finalistes hugues ou l'auront et
claude regarder
ça fait deux heures que vous tenez et
les la surface de votre poteau va se
réduire attention tiré
deux heures et cinq minutes je sais pas
comment je suis tout seul
trois heures d'épreuve laurent ugo
attention tirer
un match
la lutte aux bourreaux
quoi je lui son épouse j'ai gardé les
photos je gage et les poteaux
c'est pas aussi grand les chéris alors
en 2h37 soit 1h20 après le début de
l'émission c'est enfin le retour en
plateau à paris on s'attendait à une
édition spéciale à cause de la triche
pour ces mêmes qu'ils allaient faire un
truc de fou je vous le dis moi dis massa
les mails à partir de 17h c'est je les
prends tout le monde en face à face avec
les inspecteurs démolisseurs et jeter
spi et l'avons frère je te fais denis 7
heures à 5 heures du matin je veux te
dire je te fais un koh lanta spécial
gens lèvent tous les programmes de tf1
je fais koh lanta 17h24 heures de
terreur lanta l'initiateur jusqu'à 17
heures le lendemain voilà des
perquisitions on est parti de partout
les gars là c'est un truc de fou eux ils
ont attendu 22h37 pour en parler et en
fait ils ont fait comme si de rien
n'était rien mais dans une course ça je
voudrais nous expliquait alexia parce
que les joints hier sur les réseaux
sociaux mais je suis là pour ça qu'on
dit si l'on prend pour une armoire est
alors des roms ça veut dire des harkis
regard
ravi de vous retrouver ici à paris pour
la fin de cette saison de koh lanta la
légende alors voici tout de suite ce
dont vous avez suivi l'épopée du premier
sorti jusqu'au finalistes
[Musique]
vous êtes magnifique quel bonheur de
vous retrouver comme ça ici tous
ensemble vous êtes dix neuf aventuriers
ici ce sens puisqu'il en manque de
coumba qui est souffrante et alix qui
est obligé de respecter une période
d'isolement chez elle de retour d'un
voyage en afrique australe voilà j'étais
très sympa avec matthieu delormeau comme
toujours
donc pourquoi denis brogniart nous dit
rien de la crise est ce qu on
nous a pris pour des roms je vais
expliquer merci à lisa non alors déjà je
voulais quand même vous dire que c'est
extrêmement décevant et compliqué pour
nous mais c'est de se retrouver
confronté à ça non mais ça il faut le
dire
moi je suis avec des équipes qui
travaillent sur ce programme depuis 20
ans ce légende ça a été énormément de
travail pour nous il ya 300 personnes
qui se déplacent il faut savoir qu'il ya
des gens qui restent jusqu'à 75 jours
quand même 100 bougies en famille non
sans voir leur famille pourront
travailler sur tout au long de ta et que
pour nous réunir tente génération
d'aventuriers bien sûr été c'est un défi
et c'était on va là on mise en paiement
là dessus il ya aucun moment on a pensé
qu'on pouvait se retrouver face à moi
des gens qui disent que sa cote de leur
production parce que tous les candidats
même claude on l'a entendu hier dans une
loge et tous les cons direction du lieu
il dit sa cause la production mais alors
ça mais j'ai entendu coumba la dernière
fois alors je suis fan de one on me mets
moi elle sait que je les aime bien
combat aussi donc c'est pour ça que ça
me dit que vous êtes un amour j'aime et
où c'est tellement c'est tellement
facile de se défausser vous explique
comment ça se passe on a des aventuriers
pour certains ils ont fait jusqu'à
quatre à cinq éditions déjà de koh lanta
c'est des gens qui connaissent
parfaitement ce programme c'est des gens
qui sont respectés qu'ils sont adulés
pour certains par des enfants par des
plus âgés et qui connaissent les règles
de loyauté du programme alors on n'est
pas vous l'avez dit nous mêmes et vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs nous ne sommes pas
des procureurs nous ne sommes pas des
flics on a mis un système de
surveillance d'autant plus qu'on savait
qu'on était en polynésie c'est l'une des
rares fois on a tourné justement sur un
territoire français d'habitude on
t'aurait les étrangers donc évidemment à
l'étranger les gens ne connaissent pas
tromper les personnalités ne connaissent
même pas le programme là en l'occurrence
pour des histoires de vie dont on est
obligé tourné en polynésie donc on a
renforcé la sécurité mais on est comme
sur un principe de confiance c'est à
dire qu'on n'est pas car bien de on
n'est pas gardien de prison donc que
l'on soit trahi comme ça ne nous
trompons pas on est victime de ça on l'a
appris nous au moment de l' annonce de
thé aura donc à trois semaines à moi on
est tombé des nues quoi donc il faut il
faut des contrôles continus sakho de la
production parce qu'il aurait dû le plus
nous surveiller vous dites quoi mais
enfin c'est non mais c'est c'est comme
si alors vous savez on est tous des
truands ouais donc vous le saviez qu'on
était des truands et donc vous auriez dû
mettre des gardiens plus aguerris mais
on avait des gars des rebonds fort on ne
les a jamais prêt pour des truands pour
nous c'est des légendes donc il ya un
moment il faut pas se tromper et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on est dans un il faut
savoir les équipes chez moi c'est ultra
violent il paraît que vous êtes très
déçu de cette d'espionnage et saison et
il n'a pas déçu de la saison en soir
c'est à dire de ce qui s'est passé on a
battu des records incroyable parce que
quand même il faut pas il faut pas tout
jeter enfin le lot c'est quoi c'est bien
le bébé avec l'eau du bain mais mais
avec le débat il ya quand même eu des
records me demander comment c'est à dire
non mais je sais je sais vous êtes un
peu le la le lin police n'a plus de sens
et donc non mais c'est vrai il ya eu des
records incroyables pas été là dessus je
pense au cochon pendu bon il ya six
personnes qui ont battu des records mais
c'est vrai ça voilà il ya eu sur la
proue enfin voilà ce temps il est
tellement ce qu'elle gagnait doc a eu
des choses incroyables et des
revirements de la stratégie des choses
fantastiques donc c'est alors une très
belle saison mais mais sincèrement oui
je le reconnais je sers ni oui a dit
chan c'est bien de dire si halak c'est
ça que j'aime
oxia pourquoi vous avez évoqué la triche
ah bon alors pourquoi on n'a pas évoqué
avant quoi avant l'europe un non mais
c'est vrai 22h43 ah oui avance sur le
prime bah oui mais voilà les vrais
cracks de plusieurs points premier point
et ça on l'a dit et on a communiqué sur
nos réseaux sociaux on ne veut pas
donner non d'accord c'est à dire qu'on
sait moi je voulais donner moi j'ai des
noms mais voilà on sait on a
suffisamment de preuves et l'épreuve
réellement fondées on a un constat une
attestation d'huissier et je voulais
apporter parce que il faut savoir que
comme si l'alternative
non mais c'est important c'est donc un
constat du règlement ce que je sais que
vous avez règlement du jeu qui a déposé
ses maîtres simonin en l'occurrence
moyens un moment quand jacques ans j'ai
rassemblé à un certain nombre de preuves
je suis allé le voir et je lui dis
est-ce que vous pour vous ça constitue
une rupture du code d'honneur qui est
inscrit dans le règlement du jeu et là
il me dit je vous lis l'attestation
c'est important parce que c'est quelque
chose qui est vendu avec certains liens
qui est extérieur à la production qui
est extérieur à tf1 qui est neutre de
champ et qui est garant du règlement
donc monsieur simona confirmé atteste
avoir reçu l'ensemble des pièces et
éléments permettant d'établir le
comportement irrégulier de plusieurs
participants lors du déroulé du jeu
l'ensemble de ces pièces illustre les
manquements au code d'honneur et à
l'éthique général exposées dans le
règlement du jeu qui est déposé en mon
étude et justifie l'impossibilité de
déclarer un vainqueur pour cette saison
donc ça c'est au premier plan que c'est
ce que vous avez fait hier on va le voir
vous savez il n'y aura aucun vainqueur
cette saison regarder la décision finale
à 23h37 denis brogniart annonce la
grande décision prise par la production
et c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont dit on a attendu jusqu'à 23h30
voilà c'est vrai qu'on aurait aimé que
ça vienne 1 mais je comprends je
comprends mais l'idée n'était pas d'en
faire non plus ni un débat ça c'est
votre d'une traité l'autre méthode autre
métier de notre métier voilà c'est fait
on se régale nous ça pour ce gamin on va
en parler avec eric zemmour d'heure on
s'est dit aussi il ya quand même droite
et oui grâce à ses origines avec un pain
au chocolat oui alors il est donc oui
et l'idée c'est qu'on se dit voilà il ya
quand même des téléspectateurs qui
suivent assidûment ce programme mais qui
ne sont pas automatiquement au courant
de ce qui se passe parce que quand même
on va se le dire ok c'est dans le
parisien ok c'est dans les réseaux
sociaux mais il ya un moment on va
raconter la vraie histoire ce qui s'est
passé on va pas nier les poteaux sûr on
va pas nier voilà tout ça et on va
surtout aussi reconnaître des
aventuriers qui n'ont pas triché et en
l'occurrence hall et pourquoi pas ne pas
fait gagner tous les aventuriers qui est
pas qu'elle ait pas triché voilà il
partage et que vous avez un nom du mal à
prisches présence aurait pu être une
option pour ça il fallait qu'on révèle
as oui d'accord et oui l'accord est
soumis voulait pas révéler n'est pas
révélé pourquoi parce qu'on ne veut pas
on considère qu'on est loin des ménages
le prince avait déjà mettre en cause la
vérité aurait tellement non météo dans
mettons là par lé maire était oui c'est
important
alors tu es aura déjà c'est lui qui
s'est déclaré fautif c'est lui qu'a
bravo à lui bah ouais ouais venus s'est
dénoncé oui à ce moment là il faut se
rappeler déjà que c'était pendant le
tournage au cas ce moment là on l'a
accepté d'ailleurs sa sanction voilà
alors là je suis face à des gens au
pardon confrontés nous et je vous dirai
pas qui c'est qui nie les faits donc il
ya un moment ça s'appelle sino de la
délation mais comme vous le savez depuis
quand même long maintenant quasiment un
an et demi on saisit régulièrement le
procureur de la république parce qu il
ya d amener lynchage sur les réseaux
sociaux des appels au meurtre
est donc c'est pour ça qu'on n'était pas
d'accord ne veut pas de nous étonner
alors on va revenir sur toutes les infos
venez de dire si c'est vrai c'est donc
la société de production pourrait
poursuivre des candidats c'est oui pour
à la pause
en l'occurrence on n'a pas prévu de les
poursuivre sincèrement la sanction quand
même qui a été fait est assez quand même
très forte je pense qu'on aura rien
actuellement non il n'y a rien qui est
prévue ne seront pas interdit de manger
voilà deux hier une candidate a
volontairement poids côté la finale et
vous l'avez peut-être vu alors la
question c'est que ce ça me sentir rumba
non mais ces combats en l'occurrence
elle nous a envoyé un certificat médical
qu'est ce que je vous dise elle l'a
boycotté où elle n'a pas boycotté faut
lui demander à l d'accord apparemment
coumba g lui tu as des infos oui il
était pas malade du tout elle a dit très
clairement qu'elle ne voulait pas
cautionner ça
que moi je n'ai pas triché dit elle et
c'est anormal que l'on dépouille pas
donc je ne veux pas cautionner je ne
viens pas avec ces gens n'aient pas le
droit s'est dépouillé même de toute
façon j'en ans mais je vous dis elle
vous avons longuement voit un côté
je voulais pas venir
pourquoi la finale n'était pas en direct
pareil pas de dérapages et de red bull
mais ce que je voulais justement moi les
dîners avec mes enfants aient regardé
pour une fois la finale dans son numéro
permet non mais ça ce que hermès ont
déconné je te le dis assez
catastrophique géraldine langue de bois
ce tte publi-rédactionnel à convaincre
on a regardé toutes les missions à la
lumière de ce conseil ouais alors ça
vous avez rêvé catastrophique en
vacances mais oui soit xiam à l'excès
parce qu'elle dit vous avez raison je la
tiens c'est non mais ça n'enlève de
réunir sur une colline je comprends cela
qu'il faut à cet énervement et de toute
façon il est partagé par certains pas
par tout ça mais il partagé par certains
donc à un moment il faut que je
l'entende l'ado et même moi j'ai
considéré que la mission est un peu trop
longue et je suis d'accord avec une
partie de ce que vous dites
la seule chose c'est que on s'est dit
voilà il ya quelques candidats qui ont
fauté très clair non et on le sait vous
voilà il y en a beaucoup qui n'ont pas
fauté qu'il n'était même pas au courant
de ça donc il ya un moment on n'a pas
voulu non plus se dire que tout ce qu'on
avait montré aux téléspectateurs tout ce
qu'on avait filmé c'est tous ses records
dont je vous parlais etc c'était c'était
bidon il fallait il fallait ne rien en
faire mais alex envolée record avec des
gens qui mangent et ça c'est pas des
renoncer pas d'accorder les jeunes
bergers a pas que oui mais alors
attendue non malgré tout ranger tous ont
énormément perdre du poids on est passé
à voir notre ca c bref c'est pourquoi
j'ai perdu du poids c'est les soucis
j'avais peur de ce
territoire mais ça faisait tellement
stressée alors alexia c'est une décision
de la prod ou tf1 devrait différer de
ferrandi ferris parterre de dirigeants
beau nom mais ça c'était ça c'était
comme un d'accord déjà parce qu'on a
pour être franc avec vous on ne savait
pas la teneur du programme
encore quatre jours avant
donc voilà donc alors c'est un autre
info à cause d'une ambiance pourrie les
candidats sont tous partis
individuellement taxi après alors ça
c'est faux complètement faux puisqu'on a
eu il ya eu un petit truc derrière
c'était pas sincèrement la frette
malheureux énorme fête mais non mais
j'ose l'anarchie alexia non mais c'est
drôle et c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
pense aller manger les restes et avait
donc bien
écoutez là ça fait quand même cinq mois
euros l'une où ils ont pas rapporté
c'était quand même extrêmement non mais
très clairement c'était triste bah oui
non on est énervé là il ya beaucoup
quand même deux candidats alors des
anciens candidats comme des candidats de
cette saison qui se sentent trahis eux
mêmes oui ils ont l'impression que c'est
l'opprobre sur toute la saison nation
donc non ce n'était pas la fête mais en
revanche ils sont pas partis comme ça au
dépô t il y avait une très sale ambiance
la guérilla la vie à 26 cents de l'an
dire mais c'est clair que ça t aura été
tout seul de son côté plus personne ne
lui parle il était il était d'une
tristesse absolue moi j'ai eu des
candidats le soir qui rentrait tout seul
en taxi s'est désolé il y avait
la pêche mais qu'elle allait prendre son
vol
en fin d'année cela et c'est parti
l'échec claude et laurent et c'est les
seuls à savoir avant la finale qui
n'auraient pas cent mille euros il reste
encore plusieurs d'infos 5 infos après
c'est vrai ça non c'est faux sur son
retour
je suis allé au miroir si ces cas là
mais c'est vrai quoi moi j'aime bien son
nom mais pas cette rue le monde était au
courant qui a espacé un truc un peu
particulier ces accords parce que on les
a même après le conseil tous les
candidats ont mangé il semblerait que
lors des conseils des candidats auraient
tout de suit la possibilité de manger
gilles votre version oui c'est vrai vous
leur avez presque obligé des citrons les
fruits travis logie avait il y avait des
citronniers des piments et après le
conseil vous aviez tout un système de
contrôle quand ils allaient au conseil
dans les marques vous leur métier des
casques des lunettes par mm il paraît
même de ce que je sais qu'ils avaient
fait même un petit marché comme à rungis
où il ya des mecs elle deux mois du
poisson tu veux mais tu adoreras
l'important non les habits cloisonné et
se sont complètement échappé pour aller
servir à l'externe encore de ça pour le
coup on sait comment ça s'est passé
je ne révèle pas de nom d'accord on ne
sait pas vous révéler palais parce que
elle veut tout quoiqu'il
alexia franchement j'ai complètement
d'accord avec elle il ya des trucs sur
les réseaux sociaux demnach à la mairie
les candidats de koh lanta je comprends
les mecs les maxima qui se fasse la
manche est un jour important d'expliquer
à tout le monde comment ça se passe
après le lancer donc c'est un endroit
qui n'est pas à proximité des camps en
compte les camps sont basées sur des
motos en l'occurrence je vais parler en
moto en polynésie c'est à des tout
petits îlots extrêmement isolées le
conseil lui et si tourner le plus
important de ces pelles rail atac moto
avec les tunnels importante et en
l'occurrence le conseil à côté à
proximité du conseil il ya une tente
dans lequel résident les candidats à
l'issue du conseil pourquoi y résident
là c'est tout simplement parce qu'on
refuse depuis de nombreuses années de
faire tout ce qu'on appelle nous de la
navigation de nuit voilà pourquoi parce
que vous ne savez pas qui vous pouvez
croiser ces dangereux et c'est bon pour
des raisons de sécurité ont reçu ça il
s'est extrêmement sommaire il ya un
plancher une tente et une petite lumière
pour aller faire pipi parce que comme
ils vont faire pipi dehors va les gens
font pipi mon tour aux ententes ours à
un gardien
une dans une autre tente l'équipe de
production enfin le journal histoire les
suit et l'équipe médicale voilà nous ce
qu'on a qu'on a confronté comme beaucoup
de témoignages ce qui est unanime ce qui
nous raconte c'est que quand le gardien
sans dormait en sachant que les autres
étaient quand même pas à proximité quand
le gardien sans dormait en effet il y en
a certains qui se sont carapatés je ne
sais pas le nombre de froid car à pattes
est
en partie bloquée ce sont carapatés
cette rue est et là c'est à ce moment là
ce qui est quand même très surprenant et
si vous regardez on n'a pas google maps
mais je vois il ya quand même facilement
15 à 20 minutes de marche en pleine nuit
dans un truc est relativement tout fut
un bon tofu ce qui est pour ça aussi que
ça nous semblait extrêmement fin ça nous
semblait pour nous à errer sans même de
ne passer ça que les mecs pas tu t'es
déjà pour nous moralement on va dire ça
nous semblait impossible et en plus
physiquement ça nous semblent extrêmes
compliqué ok et donc c'est en rejoignant
il ya une sorte de pension de famille
que ça se serait déroulé pas d'accord
alors alexia autre question dîner
kandestin le nom des candidats
d'initiative enfin révélé les contenus
ou des candidats l'initiative de cette
grande tricherie serait donc clos dès
lors on ne doit pas révélé de noms a pas
le dire juste non message ne dit rien
mais alors rien ne dit rien et prient
jésus voilà dites moi ça vient du fait
religieux s'est assurée sur la torah bah
oui et bien sûr au jour également sur le
coran dans un instant oui
on jouera demain sur le courant avec l
hexagone
sélection d'une photo une photo ll
concert est une preuve il paraît que la
production est parti à tahiti pour
récupérer cette photo est ce qu'on
voulait en votre possession est-ce que
vous avez pas l'horreur qu'elle sorte
dans la presse people en tout cas ça
parce que vraiment on a les noms des
aventures et sortiront à ce moment là on
a de nombreux éléments nous n'avons pas
cette photo adacore voie d un retour 10
à côté de cette photo on nous a parlé je
ne sais pas si c'est réel ou pas
d'accord ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est
vrai pour le coup qu'on alors on n'a pas
envoyé quelqu'un de paris on peut lire
ici ils sont très clairement en revanche
si à un moment on essaie de faire un
minimum denquête et donc oui à quelqu'un
qui est parti à priori oui il existe une
photo quand même et nous on n'a jamais
eu en main d'accord cette photo bien
entendu on est en train d'enquêter
dessus et voilà cette photo pascal
rialland banalisée hier que cette photo
existe et que sachez le je le dis j'en
ai rien à [ __ ] petit à ce que ça
choque pour l'un cette photo je leur en
fond d'écran voilà et pour l'instant je
ne peux pas la révéler bien entendu
qu'on est d'ailleurs que toutes les
photos qu'on voit sur twitter ce sont
des montages vous disant voilà pour
l'instant seul ou
presque n'a pas la faute des locaux
la photo officielle n'est pas sortie
jack layton selon nos informations les
si les candidats se sont énervés c'est
surtout en apprenant les tricheries
racontée par les derniers sortis donc
trois aventuriers ont refusé de
poursuivre le tournage et serait rentré
en moto et en métropole sous escorte de
la production reste que c'est vrai c'est
faux c'est faux d'accord alexiens la
production bluff frais sur la photo du
dîner clandestins ce que vous avez dit
en fait ils ont dit qu'ils avaient qui
avait la photo c'est un moyen de se
prémunir de toute attaque mais
apparemment la production aurait fait
pression sur les candidats pour la cette
photo maintenant je vais me dire que ma
photo non mais des cas pas de photos non
mais elle existe un parti c'est une
maladie
voilà donc le trial ont même réclamé sa
libération s'est passée alizé dépression
et gilles verdez c'est vrai car photo ap
a été montré et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
deux aventuriers moi je vais mener les
noms mais c'est laurent et claude denis
et ça ça vous met en difficulté et selon
mes informations vous avez beaucoup
travaillé que vos avocats pour voir
comment vous pouvez vous en sortir c'est
pour ça c'est une cause généreuse mais
c'est pour ça que vous avez redistribuer
l'argent à la fondation bernard match
fini joueurs non parce que sinon des
aventuriers pouvait vous attaquez vous
avez étudié ça en disant nous avons un
contrat de travail rayés il fallait
redonner l'argent mais dans l'aveyron
pourquoi penser comme ça c'est non je
vous jure que ça c'est pas rentrer là
dedans oui merci non mais je le dis avec
ça le sait on n'est pas là du tout
rentrer dans ces considérations n'ont
alors attendez à ce que c'est compliqué
ce que vous avez dit alexia mais ça veut
dire là tu n'en la question c'est que
pourquoi on a donné à bertrand
kamel c'est que justement on dit c'est
ça a été
on sait les gens peut-être il ya
d'autres choses qu'on ne sait pas et en
3 de cette photo on nous en a beaucoup
parlé a priori je sais qu'ils sont sur
la photo mais je ne sais pas si elle
existe c'est ça qui est compliqué nous
ce qu'on arrête on a récupéré des
preuves qui pour le coup sont
extrêmement factuel et tangibles voilà
si vous me demandez cette photo moi je
n'ai pas dû pour être que d'autres l'ont
vu d'accord alors dernière question
essayer une des questions prennent à
plusieurs mais sur l'un foulard
après avoir menacé de faire grève les
candidats ont obtenu des pains au
chocolat alors ça aussi c'est faux déçu
alors là il s'avère tu laisses que non
les candidats ni mais c'est vrai que on
a beaucoup entendu salle et les
candidats continuent de le nier moi je
pense qu'aujourd'hui l'école je pense
qu'il n'y ait mais qui s'est passé
quelque chose avec sauna
je crois que je sais pas qui a sorti sa
lé parisien
pour vous expliquer quand même moi je ne
suis pas sur le tournage constamment en
l'occurrence je suis arrivé à la fin du
tournage ce qui s'est passé c'est que en
l'occurrence les deux aventurières on
peut le dire c'est claude lots qui
seront qui ont suite à l'épreuve des
bonbons ont gagné un confort à et les
deux voilà les deux allende versant
temps d'avoir un an les bords pourquoi
parce qu'ils avaient
là à ce moment là il arrive dans ce
qu'on appelle péripéties c'est à dire
qu'on leur fait un dilemme où il ya
courrier mais je crois qu'il ya en face
des chocolatines si je parle comme ça
tout le monde pensait que j'ai 70 ans et
son petit monde et pas au chocolat des
points chauds calais chocolat donc et
viennoiseries on va on leur a dit non
c'est un dilemme donc c'est soit un
premier courrier soit vous prenez les
animaux à ce moment là ils ont été très
mécontents le producteur est arrivé est
très simple c'est vraiment les a on
reconnaîtra les voilà à ce moment là ils
sont allés je crois dormir quelque part
donc ils n'ont jamais eu pour le coup
accès à la culture moi je cours à
l'excellent de la grèce je crois à lire
mais aussi mais juste michael holt au
breda vous venez de parler de lui du
parisien est ce qu'on à l'extrait en
régie nourdine filer tout droit parce
qu'ils les matières sèches et qui doit
rentrer chez lui naudinet scandale
extrait où il dit qu'il a reçu des
dépressions bravo mon ordi c'est bien
meilleur on est à l'histoire que theora
s'est procuré à plusieurs reprises de la
nourriture le lien secret avec
l'entourage aussi des candidats avec des
polynésiens aussi donc très vite on à
l'histoire on la confronte à la
production et tf1 qui la bloque bloque
toute communication
tentative d'intimidation ou à vous faire
un procès si vous sortez l'émission
c'est ce pôle est l'émission
non mais alors alors samoa adéquat on va
appeler michael alors oui je trouve ça
très bien on va l'appeler alors michael
alexia moi je trouve qu'il a fait un
travail fabuleux michael sur le tour
mais je ne dis pas que c'est un mauvais
jour n'a ils excellent
non pas vous pas vous pas vous mais je
pense que c est vrai qu alors je vous le
succès l'inter doit être agréé de la cob
de tf1 on sait comment ça se passe et
elle est celle qui est inquiétant et la
com de donner aux réductions et la com
de tf1 qui est en contact avec les
journalistes michaël d'auto mandat je
pense que s'il a dit ça il a pas
montille excusez moi avec certains jeux
alors qu'il n'a pas dit que c'était vous
mais je vous le dis même si l'article
avait reçu des pressions c'est
sidération des pressions c'est long mais
c'est pas bon il a pas dit que c'est
vous mais michael je ne dois pas mentir
face caméra il dira qu'il a reçu des
pressions alors qu'il en a pas voilà on
va être et leur jeu mais il ya une
grosse ombre bâtir ce koh lanta cette
histoire mais évidemment non mais non me
rend vachement dire tf1 il faut un
procès à tous ceux qui parlent de koh
lanta qui dit ce qui va se passer dans
les blancs les noms les dans les
épisodes sont là pour le coup c'est pas
été facile et vous whitehurst non là on
va chacun on va distribuer les rôles non
mais il ya une race rare et tour de
kolontar un moment c'est un jeu qua non
non alors bonjour merci bon alors de le
dire mise à part que c'est vrai qu'on a
attaqué toute personne qui le spoiler
voilà le programme mais je crois que
j'étais venu vous en parler bien sûr
voilà c'est un sujet qui est délicat
pour nous parce qu'on considère que ça
nous tue le pauvre et ça peut créer même
un préjudice cette légende a eu
connaissance qui se passe mais regarde
moi donc ça on a toujours attaqué sur la
pression sur des journalistes on ne fait
ne fait pas de pression sur les
gendarmes et s'il y en a eu sur michael
cera voilà alex ça je te lis alors je
crois tout ce que la vie a vraiment et
je te soutiens à fond la fin pour moi et
je parle et là c'est sûr qu'une
dépression j'ai envie à l on a fait de
près je vais te dire regardez du côté
plutôt de la communication de télé
manger la détresse chez bien non métaux
chez vous et moi de chez vous non mais
on aurait quelque chose à se reprocher
mais vous avez à temps
individuels n'ont été aussi un moment là
dessus mais on est des choses à se
reprocher ok je veux bien croire que
dans ces cas là on fait des pressions on
n'a rien à se reprocher je le redis je
conclus hier oui mais c'est mclean oui
mais oui mais oui me la donner et donner
des infos peuvent c'est à dire la marée
et oui on peut le programme et dallas
mais il est obligé de l'exercie répondre
merci